[Applause]
my next guests watch star wars over 400
times and his turned his passion into a
show where he acts out all the
characters and scenes from the first
three Star Wars films by himself he's
here to perform a scene from one man's
Star Wars trilogy which is currently
playing at lambs theater here in Charles
[Applause]
[Music]
a long time ago in a galaxy far far did
it Star Wars Papa Papa Star Wars there
go the yellow words describing the plot
of the entire movie before
[Music]
[Applause]
where those plans you intercepted we
know such plans this is a consular ship
we're on a diplomatic mission if this is
a consular ship and where's the
ambassador
the monetary ship apart and between the
passengers Hawk I want them live I don't
know what you're talking about
I'm on a diplomatic mission you're part
of the Rebel Alliance and a traitor who
take away holding her is dangerous
Oh leave that to me lord Vader Thanks
position x position x position x
position x position
she must have hidden the plans about the
escape pod detachment to retrieve them
more see to it personally come on there
there we no one to stop us this time yes
sir we seem to be made to suffer it's
our lot in life much too rocky I just
about had enough of you fine oh that's
way we malfunction wasn't a day you
near-sighted scrap out no no more
adventures I'm not going that way linen
that malfunctioning little twerp he
tricked me going this way but he'll do
no better wait what's that a transport
I'm saved r2d2 it is you it is you in
thin thin thin thin thin thin thin thin
limp infant Luke take these two out of
the garage I want them cleaned up before
dinner but I was going into tosche
station to pick up some power converters
[Applause]
done with yours thank the maker this oil
bath is gonna feel so good
looks like you guys have seen a lot of
actions help me 1 Kenobi you're my only
hope
help me one Kenobi you're my only hope
who is she
she's beautiful Luke I'll be right there
ampere ooh
[Music]
ah
feathered hair
we write back